la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le
procèsverbal est donc adopté sous les
réserves
d'usage notre ordre du jour appelle les
explications de vote des groupe et le
vote par scrutin public solennel sur le
projet de loi considéré comme adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale en application de
l'article 49 aléa 3 de la
Constitution de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour
2024 madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vous
rappelle que ce scrutin s'effectuera
depuis les terminaux de vote je vous
invite donc à vous assurer que vous
disposez bien de votre carte de vote et
à vérifier que celle-ci fonctionne
correctement en l'insérant dans votre
terminale de
vote vous pourrez vous rapprocher des
huissiers si vous éprouvez une
difficulté avant de passer au vote je
vais donner la parole à ceux de nos
collègues qui ont été inscrits pour
expliquer leur vote et tout
d'abord première explication de vote
Monsieur Bernard jum pour le groupe
socialiste et e et
[Applaudissements]
républain monsieur le Président Madame
et Monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission madame la
rapporteur générale mes chers
collègues durant une
nous avons débattu du budget de la
Sécurité sociale présenté par le
gouvernement un budget qui est en
déficit et qui selon la trajectoire
prévu sera au fil des ans encore plus en
déficite qu'aujourd'hui 8 milliards 11
milliards jusqu'à 17 milliards en 2027
c'est une trajectoire qui est inédite et
c'est celle d'un gouvernement qui
n'arrive pas à rétablir les comptes
sociaux et ainsi il fragilise la
sécurité sociale dans ses fondements
puisqu'il projette dans l'opinion
publique l'idée que le système n'est pas
soutenable qu'il n'est pas tenable dans
la durée et cette semaine de débat elle
a été utile parce qu'elle nous aura
confirmé que c'est un choix en effet les
dépenses de santé vous le savez
progressent plus vite que la richesse
nationale de notre pays sous l'effet de
différents facteurs la population
vieillit les problématiques de
dépendance s'accroissent et le coût de
nombreux soins augmente fortement et
tout ceci génère une hausse évaluée à 4
% par an
environ le gouvernement lui nous propose
un Nam en hausse de 3,2 % ce qui amène
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des acteurs du
monde de la santé à un avis généralisé
qui est ce budget n'est pas tenable et
d'ailleurs déjà cette année en 2023
alors que nous avions alerté l'année
dernière il a fallu majorer de 1,2 %
longam comment le gouvernement arri-t-il
à ce chiffre de + 3,2 %. c'est d'abord
l'hôpital qui est maltraité car en
raison des hausses liées aux
revalorisation qui sont bienvenus des
personnels il ne reste rien aucune marge
pour faire face à l'inflation et au
besoins du quotidien hospitalier 2024
sera encore plus dure que 2023 pour nos
hôpitaux et ce sont des activités
parfois vitales qui sont touchés la
néonatalogie par exemple ou les lignes
d'urgence premièr
mais c'est aussi le secteur de la ville
qui est concerné dans lequel les
négociations conventionnelles reprennent
avec les médecins et sans doute avec les
pharmaciens dont l'exercice en officine
est de plus en plus fragile et bien sans
qu'un seul euro ne soit inscrit à ce
budget c'est le secteur de l'autonomie
ensuite qui voit de nombreux
établissements en grande difficultés
financière et auquel il faudra apporter
des réponses et de nouveaux moyens en
2024 bien au-delà des 100 millions
abondés en cours d'examen du texte le
Bien Vieillir devait être une politique
sociale et sociétale structurante il est
pour l'instant plus un slogan et un
avorton
législatif tout indique que les dépenses
en
2024 dépasseront donc le budget voté
alors dites-moi est-ce que les recettes
sont majorées pour éviter encore plus de
déficit en matière le gouvernement
paraît ne suivre qu'une seule
orientation celle de la hausse des
recettes espéré lié à l'amélioration
espérée de l'emploi il rejette quasiment
toutes les propositions relatives à la
réduction des exonération toutes les
propositions de prélèvement portant sur
le capital et les revenus des
actionnaires et toutes celles relatives
à la fiscalité
comportementale alors quand les dépenses
augmentent et que les recettes les
couvre de moins en moins quelle solution
reste-t-il et bien nous l'avons vu nous
le voyons c'est le transfert de dépenses
hors du périmètre de la sécurité sociale
vers les ménages soit directement soit
via les organismes
complémentaires c'est donc la question
des franchises médicales et c'est la
question des baisse de remboursement des
soins
dentaires et il faut le dire cela va
continuer
nous votons un budget qui sera en cours
d'exercice modifié par voie
réglementaire j'en prends le Paris alors
bien sûr ce budget comporte des mesures
positives sur le déploiement de la
vaccination
HPV sur la santé des femmes et sur la
modification du financement des hôpitaux
dont nous approuvons les principes et
attendons les modalités maiselles ne
peuvent faire oublier le cadre général
restrictif la procrastination politique
sur la dépendance et l'inexistence de
politique affirmé sur la famille les
accidents du travail ou les maladies
professionnel ces deux derniers sujets
d'ailleurs souffrent d'un déficit très
ancien pour la prévention en définitive
cette loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale est décevante car elle n'impulse
aucun des changements profonds qui sont
indispensables au maintien d'un système
solidaire elle n'interroge pas la
dégradation des ind Atur de santé du
pays l'espérance de vie nous place
dorénavant à la 13e place des pays de
l'OCDE et la mortalité infantile vous le
savez progresse cette loi de finance ne
remet pas en cause non plus la
construction de long d'â vers une
meilleure prise en compte des besoins en
santé appuyés sur une approche
territoriale
elle ne porte pas le virage de la
prévention qui impose d'affronter avec
volontarisme les consommations de tabac
d'alcool les facteurs environnementaux
la qualité de notre alimentation et
l'activité physique enfin elle ne
contient aucune mesure de nature à
freiner la financiarisation du système
de santé qui transforme les cotisations
des assurés sociaux en revenus pour
actionnaire comment prétendre dans de
telles conditions agir sur la pertinence
des soins
elle laisse enfin les pénuries multiples
se répandre alors vous l'avez compris
nous estimons madame le ministre
monsieur le ministre que le budget que
vous nous présenter est une impasse
alors que la crise sanitaire qui a surgi
en 2020 est derrière nous les
enseignements n'en sont pas tirés alors
qu'il faudrait réunir un large accord
politique pour rénover en profondeur
notre protection sociale et notre
système de santé la faiblesse de votre
base politique empêche le Parlement de
remplir pleinement son rôle les
contournement du type CNR ne règle rien
le résultat est là et nous le dés
trouvons je vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
corinaert pour le groupe des
[Applaudissements]
Républicains vous avez la parole ma
chère
collègue merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur générale mes chers collègues
la sécurité sociale est un bien précieux
et son budget est bien supérieur à celui
de l'État mais hélas ce PLFSS pour 2024
nous a été présenté en demi-teinte
offrant une lueur de proposition
encourageante noyé dans tant d'autres
propositions profondément D s vente je
veux évoquer avec vous aujourd'hui mes
regrets qui sont à la hauteur du devoir
qui nous incombe ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale est
un aveu d'impuissant sur le plan
budgétaire par l'abandon de l'objectif
des retours à l'équilibre le
Gouvernement transmet la dette sociale
aux générations futures sans l d'un
embarras auquel ce fardeau se prête
pourtant car il s'agit bien ici de
milliards qui sont en jeu déjà plus
important que l'an dernier le déficit
devrait se creuser davantage au cours
des prochaines années pour inteindre
plus de 17 milliards d'euros à l'horizon
2026 et
2027 pour cette raison le groupe les
républicains rel rejoint l'analyse de la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat sur la trajectoire financière de
ce PLFSS dont nous déplorons
l'insincérité et
l'incohérence succédant la crise
sanitaire le contexte inflationniste
engendre une hausse vertigineuse de l'
d'â passant de 200 milliards d'euros en
2019 à 255 milliards d'euros en 2024
véritable boîte noire le Sénat n'a
d'autre choix que de le rejeter devant
un tel manque de transparence si la
rassurance maladie poursuivra aussi et
ainsi en 2024 une trajectoire de
dépenses dynamique le gouvernement ne
prend lui pas la peine de justifier ni
d'affiner l'enveloppe pour la
représentation nationale ni d'en ni d'en
détailler les économies prévues à
hauteur de 3,5 milliards d'euros en
témoigne explicitement le sujet de la
hausse des franchises et de la
participation forfaitaire
malheureusement trop
caricaturale si le soutien la
vaccination du papilloma virus humain
est bienvenue il constitue la seule
mesure de prévention tandis que la
prescription d'antibiotiques par les
pharmaciens pour les engines et les
cisti et la seule en matière
d'amélioration de l'accès aux soins mes
chers collègues la prévention et
l'amélioration de l'accès aux soins ne
peuvent en rester là c'est pourquoi nous
avons a SII souhaité diminuer les
rendez-vous non honorés source de
gaspillage de temps médical parce qu'il
devient indispensable de responsabiliser
davantage les patients dans la prise de
rendez-vous cette mesure de bon sang je
le crois portera ses fruits en matière
de sensibilisation de chacun et de
chacune je vous parlais de regret en
voilà un autre la profonde voir
inquiétante impréparation du
Gouvernement sur ce texte puisque nous
avons jugé que la réforme du financement
de l'hôpital est trop précipitée nous
l'avons reporté au 1er janvier 2028
après 3 années d'expérimentation pour ne
pas mettre en danger les hôpitaux nous
ne pouvons que regretter la méthode du
gouvernement qui sans étude d'impact ni
de financement complémentaire entend
poursuivre son ambition des de prudence
mes chers collègues nous devons refuser
de jouer avec l'hôpital pour répondre à
un effet
d'annonce sur les produits de santé une
divergence avec le Gouvernement en la
matière en matière de pénurie c'est
l'obligation de la dispensation de
l'unité c'est une à l'unité c'est une
fausse bonne idée et nous avons noté la
timidité du gouvernement en faveur de la
substitution par des médicaments
biosimilaires la précipitation de paire
avec la préparation se retrouve par
ailleurs dans l'abandon à mi-chemin de
l'article 39 la suppression purure et
simple de cet article est une brillante
démonstration des mesures mal anticipées
concoctées à la hâte un temps de
concertation supplémentaire est
souhaitable voire nécessaire avant
d'adopter des modifications aussi
substantielles sur le régime de la rente
ATMP la branche famille c'est la grande
oubliée de ce PLFSS grâce aux
modifications du Sénat les familles se
voient transférer 2 milliards d'euros
issu de la branche maladie vers la
branche famille ces 2 milliards
répondent au précédents transfert depuis
l'assurance maladie maternité de la
charge du congé de maternité post-natale
cette mesure répondait à une logique
comptable et masque un manque d'ambition
en faveur d'une politique familiale ce
congé n'est pas plus que la grossesse un
mode de garde mais il relève bien de la
santé tant qu'il n'y aura pas de budget
pour soutenir les familles il n'y aura
pas de véritable politique nataliste
dont le pays a besoin j'voque j'évoquer
avec vous une lueur de mesures optimiste
en voici une proposée par le groupe les
républicains la possibilité pour les
orphelins dont les parents sont affiliés
au régime des artisans des commerçants
et des professions libérales de
bénéficier d'une pension de reversion si
cette mesure de justice sociale
concernait déjà les fonctionnaires et
les salariés du privé depuis l'année
dernière notre groupe a élargi les
critères d'éligibilité à la pension de
reversion des orphelins en situation
d'handicap éloigné de l'emploi avec ACC
cœur la prise en compte des besoins de
nos territoires et pour soutenir nos
départements qui doivent assumer de plus
en plus de charges financières en
matière de dépendance et de handicap
nous avons voté le maintien de 250
millions d'euros relatif au plafond de
compensation par la Cisse nationale de
solidarité pour l'autonomie en faveur
des départements de la prestation de
compensation du handicap et de
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
nous avons adopté la proposition du
gouvernement qui tend à verser au
département un complément au concours à
pas de 150 millions d'euros et la
transformation en expérimentation de la
fusion des sections soins et dépendances
pour le financement des éepades nous
regrettons et que ces montants soient
bien en dessous des besoins financiers
des départements surtout si le
gouvernement ne s'en tient qu'à sa
proposition de 150 millions d'euros nous
attendons toujours de pieds ferme une
réforme sur le financement du secteur de
la dépendance et du handicap nous avons
aussi renforcé les droits des élus
locaux en matière de retraite depuis le
1er septembre 2023 l'ensemble des élus
peuvent cotiser au régime général sur
ses indemnités sur simple demande auprès
de leur collectivité nous avons
désormais intégré à ce champ les des
collectivités territoriales membres des
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale afin de parachever
l'avancée en matière de droit à la
retraite nous nous réjouissons également
de la suppression de la disposition
prévoyant une contribution de
l'archicarco au système de retraite non
l'État n'a pas à ponctionner les caises
de l'gicarco constitué de l'excédent
obtenu par les efforts des salariés si
l'État souhaite financer de nouvelles
dépenses qu'il fasse des économie car
oui mes chers collègues veuillez croire
que des économies sont bel et bien
possibles il est envisageable de
réaliser un 1 milliard d'euros
d'économie par an pendant plusieurs
années notamment grâce à une lutte
contre la fraude renforcée et par des
contr des contrôles accrus sur les actes
médicaux redondants c'est pourquoi nous
voulons rendre obligatoire d'ici à 3 ans
le contrôle biométrique des retraités
résidentss à l'étranger et intégrer des
agents des conseils départementaux aux
échanges d'information entre les agents
de l'État et des organismes de
protection sociale c'est vers ce chemin
que nous devons poursuivre faire de la
lutte contre la fraude à l'assurance
maladie un cheval de bataille parce que
les Français mite quon parle de santé de
prévention de politique familiale et du
Bien vieillir car nos aînés attendent
que nous trouvions des solutions pour la
prise en charge du grand âge et de la
dépendance parce que l'ensemble des
professionnels mérite que nous
discutions du déficit budgétaire des
établissements de santé des
établissements médicaux-soaux parce que
les familles méritent que l' son pche
vers une politique nataliste et un
meilleur équilibre pour
concilier au mieux la vie
professionnelle et familiale et en
raison de l'ampleur des enjeux auxquels
fait face ce PLFSS le groupe les
républicains votera ce texte dans sa
version modifié par le Sénat je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe la parole est à Stéphane
Ravier 3
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale nous
avons l'impression d'être comme l'arche
de Bery noyé dans la scène et de
continuer la brasse coulé de ces
dernières années la balance sociale est
toujours aussi déséquilibrée les
dépenses qui atteignent 255 milliards
d'euros sont à hausse de 3,2 % par
rapport à 2023 le déficit quant à lui
est amené à se creuser de 17,5 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2027 et tout cela selon
vos vos précisions les plus optimistes
alors que près de 60 % des Français
auraient déjà renoncé à se soigner soit
en raison de délai d'attente soit en
raison du coût de la consultation vous
vous apprêtez à rajouter un impôt sur la
santé en augmentant la franchise à la
charge des patients sur les boîtes de
médicaments et sur les consultation dans
la ruralité comme dans les métropoles
les maternités les services d'urgence
ferment définitivement ou épisodiquement
pour ne pas sombrer la France et les
hôpitaux reculent les déserts médicaux
progressent et malgré cela vous imposez
une aostérité de 600 millions d'euros
aux hôpitaux pour dégrossir la bête vous
choisissez de retirer le squelette au
lieu de réduire les graisses pendant que
le soin et l'accueil de la vie recule
l'idéologie elle progresse le système de
sécurité sociale auquel nous cotisons
tous très largement rembourse les
transitions de genre et les
détransitions qui s'en suivent l'État
finance également des salles de shoot
bientôt dans nos rues à Marseille alors
qu'à l'approche de l'hiver certains
médicaments de première nécessité comme
laamoxiciline manque dans de nombreuses
pharmacies nous sommes très loin des
inspirations du catholicisme social à
l'origine de notre modèle de protection
sociale l'idéologie a pris le pas sur la
solidarité j'en veux encore pour preuve
à partir du 1er octobre la prise en
charge des soins dentaires par
l'assurance maladie est passé de 70 à 60
% et dans le même temps vous proposez la
gratuité des préservatifs et des
protections hygiéniques pour les moins
de 26 ans le socialisme vous aveugle
vous êtes les ministres vous êtes les
ministres chargés de financer la santé
des Français pas leur sexualité il faut
en revenir au régaliens et cesser de
régaler mais le pire est à venir avec ce
projet de loi sur l'euthanasie visant à
éliminer les coûteux pensionnaires du
système de sécurité sociale là où vous
trouvez incapable de contribuer au bien
vieillir enfin alors que les
départements peinent à soutenir les
structures d'aide à domicile et les
épades vous avez déclaré monsieur le
ministre que la Cour des comptes ne
pourrait pas avoir le détail du nombre
des cartes vitales en circulation dans
notre pays mais dans quel genre de
régime vivons-nous en l'absence de
transparence et de contrôle nous sommes
obligés de croire que leurs chiffrage
actuel sont minimalistes et pourtant ils
annoncent 75 millions d'assurés sociaux
en France pour 67 millions d'habitants
soit 8200000 assurés sociaux en trop
dans le système 8200000 mes chers
collègues la sociale est la seule
industrie qui se développe encore dans
notre pays elle est une gigantesque
injustice nationale et sanitaire sans
aucune évolution dans ce domaine et je
conclus et malgré les avances du Sénat
je me refuserai de donner mon aval à
votre texte
merci la parole est à notre collègue
marieclaude l'ermite pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et
territoirez la parole mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président madames
monsieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteur générale Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues cette année encore l'examen du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale a été l'occasion de
débats importants sur l'orientation
budgétaire que nous souhaitons donner à
notre pays en la
matière je souhaite d'abord remercier et
saluer le travail mais aussi la
pédagogie des rapporteur notamment de la
rapporteur générale jusque vendredi soir
ils ont fait en sorte que nous puissions
participer à des débats de qualité sur
ce sujet
majeur le texte que nous avons à voter
aujourd'hui traduit deux aspects celui
de la situation budgétaire de la
sécurité sociale et celui des choix que
nous faisons en faveur de nos
concitoyens pour les prochaines
années chaque année nous ne pouvons que
déplorer l'augmentation du déficit et
l'évolution des prévisions annoncées
pour les années suivantes pour 2024
c'est un déficit de 8 milillards 8 en
2027 il atteindra 17 milliard et demi du
jamais vu depuis 2012 hors période covid
cet abîme de milliards au-dessus duquel
nous nous penchons doit vraiment nous
alerter sans pour autant nous conduire à
un immobilisme en matière de protection
sociale la peur de continuer à creuser
le déficit doit toutefois guider nos
choix nos bons choix ceux qui permett
aux Français de continuer à bénéficier
de la sécurité sociale dans les
meilleures conditions sans risquer de
remettre en question l'existence même de
ce qui fait la force de notre
République c'est exactement ce choix
qu'avait fait le Sénat en mars dernier
en adoptant le recul de l'âge du départ
à la retraite tout en tenant compte des
carrières longues de la pénibilité ou
encore de la
maternité cette réforme n'empêchera pas
à court terme la branche vieillesse de
creuser son déficit
elle illustre en tout cas la capacité du
Sénat à prendre ses responsabilités et
les mesures qui s'imposent aussi
impopulaire soit-elle et ce pour
sauvegarder notre système de
retraite pour le PLFSS 2024 queles sont
ces choix ce texte contient des avancées
très concrètes pour nos concitoyens
grâce à la prise en charge de
préservatif et de protection féminine
réutilisable pour les jeunes la
possibilité pour les pharmaciens de
délivrer dans un cadre précis certains
médicaments de première urgence sans
prescription médicale ou encore la
simplification de l'accès à la
complémentaire santé
solidaire ces mesures représentent des
apports dont beaucoup de Français
pourront bénéficier et il est bon de
constater le consensus qui peut exister
au moins sur ces
sujets comme tous certainement ici nous
partageons l'idée selon laquelle la clé
de voûte de tout système de santé doit
être la prévention nous nous réjouissons
sont des précisions que le texte apporte
concernant les rendez-vous de prévention
aux âge-clés de la vie et la proposition
de vaccination dès le collège contre le
papiom virirus humain surtout quand on
connaît l'efficacité du vaccin lorsqu'il
est administré avant le début de la vie
sexuelle sur le terrain de la prévention
nous avons d'ailleurs suivi avec intérêt
les débats autour d'une plus forte
taxation des boissons sucrées et
produits sucrés c'est une question qui
mérite d'être posée même si nous ne
partageons pas nécessairement l'idée que
l'augmentation des taxes soit la
meilleure réponse à apporter à un
problème de santé publique nous pensons
que privilégier la prévention et
l'éducation sur ces sujets qu'il
s'agisse du sucre du tabac ou de
l'alcool est une démarche plus vertueuse
qu'une mesure
punitive ce texte prévoit également le
renforcement des contrôles des arrêts de
travail leur impact dans les comptes de
la branche maladie est une réalité que
l'augmentation soit dû à l'évolution de
leur nombre ou à celle du montant des
indemnités journalières il faut dans
tous les cas un meilleur encadrement
pour éviter les abus certes ils ne sont
pas majoritaires mais ils demeurent une
réalité nous partageons aussi les
précisions qui ont pu être apportter à
l'encadrement des arrêts délivrés par
télémédecine le texte propose des outils
de lutte contre la fraude aux cotisation
sociale et nous regrettons que l'article
6 concernant les micro-entrepreneurs de
plateformes numérique é été
supprimé nous regrettons que le texte ne
soit pas à la hauteur du défi de la
dépendance sur ce point la réalité
dépasse nettement les ambitions du texte
vous le savez le nombre de seniiors de
plus de 85 ans va doubler d'ici à
2040 l'intégralité des emplois promis
auprès de nos aînés doit être créée dès
maintenant et non pas lors du prochain
quinquena nous regrettons un texte
quelque peu lacunaire sur le
développement des soins palliatifs
le gouvernement affiche pour fin 2024
l'ambition de couvrir tous les
départements d'une unité de soins
palliatif j'espère que cet objectif sera
satisfait en tout cas il doit être un
préalable à toute modification de la loi
cl
Leonetti enfin longam affiché un montant
de 250,9 milliards d'euros soit 3,2 % de
plus par rapport à
2023 si ce montant nous semblait
insuffisant pour les hôpitaux comme pour
le secteur médico-social nous ne
partageons pas les raisons invoquées
ayant conduit à la suppression du texte
vendredi dernier le groupe des
indépendants s'abstiendra sur ce
texte
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Olivier HUD pour le groupe de l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de commission madame la
rapporteur générale mesdames Messieurs
les rapporteurs chers collègu mes
premiers mots seront pour remercier la
rapporteur générale la qualité de son
travail la précision de ses propos et la
pertinence de ces amendements remercier
monsieur le rapporteur de commission qui
a parfois été au four et au moulin et
toute la commission toute l'équipe des
affaires sociales pour la préparation et
l'exécution de ce débat sur le PLFSS des
remerciement aussi pour les ministres
qui ont siégé au banc et qui sont sortis
souvent de leurs fiches et ont cherché à
argumenter et animer ce débat donc merci
pour la forme seulement il y a le fond
et le texte du PLFSS lui-même et tout au
long de ce débat on a entendu beaucoup
de qualificatifs sur ce plfs s plat
décevant désabusé pour nous groupe US
nous dirons que c'est un
PLFSS désenchanté désenchanté comme la
célèbre chanson de milen Farmer un PLFSS
qui nage dans les EAU troubles du
déficite
9 milliards en 2024 mais surtout une
trajectoire préoccupante 17 milliards en
2027 c'est une trajectoire qui donne le
vertige mes chers collègues un pays qui
s'endte pour financer sa protection
sociale un pays qui reporte le
financement de sa protection sociale sur
les générations futures est un pays qui
va mal un pays qui va très mal et ce
pays c'est la
France je crains monsieur le ministre
madame la ministre que l'histoire jugera
sévèrement cette période d'endettement
public le PLFSS n'a pas pris en compte
le changement de monde la fin de
l'argent pas cher et la hausse des taux
d'intérêt à ce sujet l'argument prononcé
par un ministre selon lequel le déficit
du PLFSS était bien peu de chose comparé
au déficit du PLF et pour nous le groupe
US et la majorité sénatoriale
irrecevable et incongru notre pays
compte 3050 milliards de dettes un
service de la dette bientôt de 74
milliards d'euros par an supérieur au
budget de l'Éducation nationale et ça
nous oblige à agir c'est d'ailleurs dans
la tribune de dimanche hein monsieur le
ministre alors quel solution à gauche
j'ai écouté Bernard jaumier toujours la
même réponse l'augmentation des
prélèvements souvent en préconisant la
suppression des exonérations de charges
patronnal et salarial d'abord
permettez-moi de douter de votre
crédibilité sur le sujet en effet vous
préconisez l'augmentation des recettes
quand vous êtes dans l'opposition mais
quand vous êtes au pouvoir vous faites
le cice ce qui en matière d'exonération
de charge fut et reste tout sauf neutre
mais passons C son d'ê taquin et
revenons au fond nous consacrons 33,3 %
du PIB à la notre prot setion sociale
un/ers de notre richesse alors que la
moyenne européenne est de 29 % et donc
je dis à à Bernard jaumier je partage
les propos que le déficit du PLFSS
pourrait être un poison mortel pour
notre système de protection sociale mais
je lui dis aussi qu'il y a un autre
poison pour le PLFSS et pour notre
société d'ailleurs tout autant mortel
voire peut-être plus foudroyant c'est
l'augmentation des prélèvements taxes
divers cotisations tel le sket connu
celui des frères raptou il n'y a qu'un
seul remède possible pour notre système
de protection sociale celui des réformes
structurelle qui implique du courage
politique pour générer d'importantes
économies pas la politique du du rabot
celle des franchises par-ci par là par
exemple qui revient à gérer la pénurie
finalement mais celle des réformes
structurelles qui par exemple pose
clairement la question de la pertinence
des soins des actes médicaux et surtout
de la
suradministration de notre notre système
de
santé si ces remarques peuvent
s'appliquer à toutes les branches elles
s'appliquent en priorité à la branche
maladie il faut revoir notre
organisation pour la médecine de ville
et notre organisation et notre
management du système hospitalier sur la
branche autonomie nous avons des débats
intéressants comme celui de la fusion
des budgets soins et dépendan dans les
épades nous sommes favorable à cette
expérimentation à une condition et pas
des moindres qu'elle ne soit à aucun
prix l'occasion d'une recentralisation
par le transfert de la tutelle des
épades sur les ARS pour nous le
département doit encore renforcer sa
place d'organisateur de l'action sociale
dans la totalité de ses composantes
enfin pour la branche autonomie il y a
urgence à aborder courageusement une loi
autonomie ça a été dit pour le grand âge
et le handicap sur le plan des moyens
mais aussi celui de la gouvernance pour
nous la CNSA n'est pas ou n'est plus un
outil pertinent pour le pilotage
paritariste de cette branche là aussi
nous souhaitons que les départements
puissent s'impliquer davantage dans le
pilotage de la branche autonomie sur la
branche retraite une remarque à certains
collègues dans le même élan vous
dénoncez la brutalité de la réforme et
regrettez qu'elle est trop peu encore
d'impact financier c'est incohérent mes
chers collègues cette réforme des des
retraites aura un impact financier réel
dans 5 ans et pas avant car des
décisions ont été prises et ce n'est pas
neutre en faveur des petites retraites
et des carrières hachées c'est une
réalité merci René Paul Savari en enfin
la branche famille la branche famille la
grande oubliée rien ou presque rien sur
le tiers payant du complément de mode de
garde sur le congé parentale sur
l'universalité des allocations
familiales ou le service public de la
petite enfance cette pauvreté de la
politique familiale est une nouvelle
illustration que ce gouvernement n'est
pas suffisamment tourné vers l'avenir
alors même que notre natalité chute de
850000 naissances à 700000 naissances
mes chers collègues ce P FSS demeure un
texte financier son équilibre ou plutôt
l'absence d'équilibre résulte de choix
surtout d'ailleurs de non choix
politique du gouvernement c'est grave et
nous refusons de nous y habituer de nous
résoudre bien sûr pour conclure le
groupe UC votfs
sorti des débats du Sénat parce qu'il
est bien meilleur que celui adopté par
493 à l'Assemblée nationale je vous
remercie merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à notre colèg
Anne Souiris pour le groupe écologist
solidarité et
[Applaudissements]
territoire
avez la
parole monsieur le Président madames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de commission madame la
rapporteur générale mesdames et et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues vendredi dernier nous avons
rejeté
l'ondame pour 2024 pour la première fois
dans l'examen du projet de loi nous
avons approché le cœur du débat l'avenir
de la sécurité sociale permettez-moi d'y
revenir en guise de préliminaire londame
est-il un outil pilotable l'ensemble des
bancs ou presque a répondu non l'ondâ
a-t-il été piloté depuis la crise
sanitaire le gouvernement a répondu non
l'ondame tel qu'il est présenté au
Parlement est-il un outil démocratique
ement satisfaisant encore non notre
groupe a rejeté londame mais
contrairement à la majorité sénatorial
il ne s'agissait pas de sanctionner une
dérive de longam ou de condamner des des
dépenses excessives d'assurance maladie
et que d'hypocrisie lors de notre débat
alors que le déficit de la Sécurité
sociale s'aggrave au fil des années et
atteint 8,8 milliards d'euros en 2021 3
la majorité sénatoriale et le
gouvernement ont rejeté nos propositions
de nouvelles recettes notre amendement
visant à créer une cotisation sur les
super profits aurait généré à lui seul
10 milliards d'euros de recettes pour la
sécurité sociale et aurait rétabli sans
aucune autre taxe une justice sociale
nécessaire maisainten non ainsi faute de
perspective avons-nous rejeté longâ en
l'absence d'une trajectoire claire de
financement permettant de garantir la
sécurité sociale face à une voie en
d'autres termes illusoire dans ses
moyens sans issue dans sa
réalité soyons précis à quel défi
fallait-il s'attaquer pour sauver notre
sécurité sociale et répondre aux enjeux
d'avenir je vous parle là d'une réalité
urgence hospitalière engorgé difficulté
de trouver un médecin généraliste en
secteur 1 possibilité moindre de
bénéficier d'une retraite avant de
mourir accès au soins réduits lorsqu'on
n'est pas français inégalité devant
l'achat d'un fauteuil roulant je vous
parle simplement de notre contrat social
de solidarité de fraternité et d'égalité
je le répète je sais que dans cette
hémicyclle même sur les bancs du
gouvernement nous sommes nombreux et
nombreux à partager l'idéal de cette
conquête sociale à se battre à nous
battre pour que les plus précaires aient
accès aux droits fondamentaux à
souhaiter que la sécurité sociale soit
garanti or ce texte n'apporte aucune
solution à la désertification médicale
ni aux problématiques d'accès aux soins
aucune solution à l'épidémie de maladie
chronique et à la santé environnementale
aucune solution à la réduction des
inégalités et à légal accès au droit il
manque pour l'hôpital public 1 milliard
d'euros à notre pays des milliers de
professionnels de santé en un mot face à
l'urgence écologique sociale économique
il lu fallu un virage majeur pour
préserver la sécurité social protéger
les plus précaires ce texte n'amorce pas
ce virage ressemblant plus à un patchwk
bricolé qu' un plan de financement
soyons clairvoyant le gouvernement
engagera sa respons é devant l'Assemblée
nationale pour faire adopter le texte
budgétaire qu'il souhaite pauvre
démocratie je compte sur vous messieurs
les ministre et Madame la Ministre pour
protéger pour le moins les mesures
utiles que nous avons intégré à ce
projet de loi et que nous pouvons
partager quels que soi nos désaccords
notamment en terme de prévention
l'intensification de l'information et la
sensibilisation dans les établissements
scolaires pour que la campagne vaccinale
contre le HPV soit un succès
l'amélioration de la continuité de la
prise en charge des frais de santé des
Françaises et des Français à l'étr de
l'étranger qui viennent se réinstaller
en France la création d'une taxe sur les
publicités pour les jeux d'argent et de
hasard la suppression de la ponction
dans les caisses d'assurance chômage le
maintien de la contribution tarifaire
d'acheminement vers la Caisse nationale
des industries électriques et gazièr
pour le financement des pensions de
retraite mais
certains enjeux majeurs de santé et de
la protection sociale n'ont pu être
correctement discutés la semaine
dernière et ont été finalement balayés
nous ne pouvons faire l'économie de la
santé environnementale de la démocratie
sanitaire de la réduction des risques de
la santé communautaire de la lutte
contre les adductions tout cela dont le
texte ne s'empar pas à l'heure où le
gouvernement a ouvert la consultation
publique pour la stratégie de santé 2023
2033 je l'invite à venir nous la
présenter et notre et notre Commission a
proposé un débat en ce cadre elle manque
aujourd'hui cruellement vous l'aurez
compris le groupe écologiste solidarité
et territoire considère ce texte
insuffisant pour répondre aux enjeux
contemporains de la santé et de la
protection sociale malgré quelques
mesures de prévention et le début d'une
autre tarification hospitalière ce
projet de loi propose un statut qu
financement business as usual et le
navire sécurité sociale poursuit sa
navigation sans voir l'iceberg sur
lequel il fonce pour la santé et le
social comme pour le climat il n'y a pas
de business as usual il y a un naufrage
annoncé et nous vogons à bord d'un
Titanic que nous croyons insubmersible
mais qui sans prise de conscience rapide
coulera assurément préparons-nous il y a
urgence pour garantir notre uré sociale
et environnementale notre groupe votera
donc contre ce texte
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Sylvana
syvan pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen
écologisteole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur générale Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues nous avons achevé l'examen de
ce budget de la Sécurité sociale pour
2024 durant 5 jours et 4 nuits nous
avons examiné 830 amendements sur un
budget de
640 milliards d'euros quel bilan
tirons-nous de ces débats la copie du
gouvernement adopté à l'Assemblée
nationale avec un passage en 493 était
très médiocre et surtout largement
insuffisante nous l'avons dénoncé dans
nos interventions le budget de la santé
est largement insuffisant pour répondre
aux difficultés rencontrées dans les
hôpitaux aux difficultés liées aux
pénuries de médicaments aux difficultés
pour avoir un rendez-vous avec un
médecin le budget des branches famille
et accident du travail maladie
professionnelle est également sous-doté
et dénué de vision politique ambitieus
ce qui est très regrettable
le budget pour 2024 de la branche
autonomie est aux antipodes des besoins
rencontrés par le secteur du
médico-social et aux antipodes des
futurs besoins engendrés par le
vieillissement de la population enfin le
budget de l'assurance vieillesse
démontre l'inefficacité de la
contre-réforme des retraites qui devait
permettre le retour à l'équilibre et qui
va finalement aggraver le déficit de 12
milliards d'euros en
2027 le gouvernement a librer son budget
de la Sécurité sociale pour dev M4 sur
des mesures d'économie sur le dos des
assurés sociaux en renforçant par
exemple le contrôle des arrêts de
maladie ou en déremboursant les soins
dentaires et que que devons-nous retenir
des modification apporté par la majorité
sénatoriale tout au long de l'examen de
ce PLFSS le gouvernement et la majorité
sénatorial ont d'une même voix rejeté
par dogmatisme tous nos amendements de
proposition de nouvelles recettes nous
avons proposé pour notre part de lutter
plus fortement contre la fraude au
cotisation patronale ce qui rapporterait
8 milliards d'euros nous avons proposé
de mettre à contribution les bénéfices
record réalisés par les entreprises en
créant une contribution des revenus
financiers en augmentant le taux de la
CSG sur les produits financiers et en
créant une contribution de solidarité
des actionnaires ce qui rapporterait
près de 40 milliards d'euros nous avons
proposé d'instituer une contribution
sociale exceptionnel des sociétés
réalisant des super profits ce qui
rapporterait 10 milliards d'euros nous
avons proposé d'instituer l'égalité
salariale femme homme ce qui
rapporterait 5 milliards d'euros enfin
nous avons proposer de supprimer les
exonérations de cotisation sociale ce
qui rapporterait 4 7,9 million d'euros
vous avez refusé 150 milliards d'euros
de recettes supplémentaires pour des
raisons dogmatiques de défense des
entreprises et des plus aisés la
majorité sénatoriale a par ailleurs
accordé 1,2 milliard d'euros
d'exonération de cotisation sociale
supplémentaire aux entreprises par
ailleurs la majorité
sénatoriale réduit encore les dépenses
pour les assurés sociaux en créant une
taxe lapin pour les rendez-vous médicaux
non honorés la copie du gouvernement a
donc été aggravée par la droite
sénatoriale comment ne pas être en
colère face à l'incapacité du
gouvernement et de la majorité
sénatoriale de tirer les conséquences de
l'échec des politiques de réduction des
dépenses si les hôpitaux publics
subissent les désertions en masse des
professionnels de santé c'est en raison
de la dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail des décennies de coupes
budgétaire ont imposé un travail de plus
en plus pénible à l'hôpital les hôpitaux
sont devenus des organisations
maltraitantes qui usent les personnels
et dégradent la qualité des soins les
personnels de santé et du médico-social
ont pourtant sont pourtant profondément
attachés au service public et à la
qualité de la prise en charge des
patientes et des patientes notre modèle
de sécurité sociale est dangereusement
remis en cause par les exonérations de
cotisation patronale le patronat qui
face à la pression fiscale et au montant
des cotisations sociales pourtant les
exonérations patronales n'ont jamais été
aussi importante la réduction des
cotisations patronnales acté encore
récemment pour l'argir Carco transfèt le
financement de la sécurité sociale des
entreprises sur nos concitoyens au point
que c'est désormais notre pacte social
qui tangue
dangereusement après le vote du Sénat le
gouvernement va pouvoir gainé une
dernière fois le 493 à l'Assemblée
nationale pour l'examen en nouvelle
lecture du PLFSS 2024 ce qui ouvrira le
bal des textes financiers dont les
députés ontt été privés de vote en
conclusion ce PLFSS 2024 est un
rendez-vous manqué pour un financement à
la hauteur des besoins sociaux mais
également un rendez-vous manqué pour
reprendre la main sur la maîtrise
publique de la production de
médicaments lors de nos débats le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales a souligné à plusieurs reprises
son souhait que la Commission se
saisisse de certains dossiers sachez que
nous sommes volontaires pour y
participer pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons les sénatrices et sénateurs du
groupe communiste républicain citoyens
et écologistes canaki qui ont porté un
autre projet que le vôtre pendant tous
les débats
voteront contre ce PLFSS pour 2024 je
vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
Véronique
Guillotin pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
[Applaudissements]
européen monsieur le Président Madame
Monsieur le Ministre messieurs les
présidents de commission madames
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues 642 milliards d'euros de
dépenses et 631 milliards d'euros de
recettes voilà l'essentiel de ce que
nous nous apprêtons à voter un budget
colossal marqué par un déficit tout
aussi colossal de plus de 10 milliards
d'euros l'an prochain alors que nous
approchions l'équilibre avant le covid
que nous espérions une amélioration avec
la fin de la crise sanitaire et la
réforme des retraites les prévisions
pour les années à venir ne sont pas très
optimiste l'annexe A de ce projet de loi
prédit un déficit débranch maladie et
vieillesse plus élevé en 2027 qu'en 2024
alors même que les prévisions de
croissance seraient surestimé d'après
l'analyse du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques une trajectoire qui a été
rejetée par la grande majorité de cette
hémicycle pour notre groupe ce rejet
traduit une inquiétude inquiétude sur la
soutenabilité de notre système de santé
inquiétude pour les générations futures
à qui nous transmettons cette dette et
inquiétude sur la financiarisation de la
santé
mais admettons-le la situation est
complexe entre réduire les dépenses mais
quell dépenses tout le monde ici nous
dit que sur son territoire c'est
compliqué que les hôpitaux ont du mal à
trouver de l'argent et augmenter les
recettes sans porter atteinte à la
compétitivité de nos entreprises ni
dégrader le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens avouons que la marge est
particulièrement étroite à l'horizon
2050 la population française comptera
près de 20 millions de personnes âgées
dont 4 millions en perte d'autonomie à
cela s'ajoute explosion des maladies
chroniques et l'arrivée des nouvelles
thérapeutiques innovantes qui coûteront
plus cher c'est une évidence nous aurons
besoin de plus de soignants à qui l'on
doit proposer de bonnes conditions de
travail il n'est donc pas difficile de
comprendre que certaines dépenses de
santé vont continuer à croître pour
autant nous ne pouvons laisser la
situation se dégrader sous nos yeux nous
sommes ainsi convaincus qu'un travail de
fond et de long terme doit être mené
nous devons examiner je dis
courageusement oui tous courageusement
et tabou la pertinence des soins le coût
de la gestion administrative de notre
système de santé pointé du doigt par la
Cour des comptes qui conclut que si le
système français a l'avantage de
garantir un reste à charge
particulièrement faible il est
particulièrement coûteux en frais de
gestion elle préconise aussi de faire en
sorte que les financements de la
sécurité sociale et des mutuels dont les
frais de gestion augmentent ne se
superposent plus ce qui est souvent le
cas à l'heure actuelle la
suradministration représente 5,6 % des
dépenses totales de santé notamment du
fait de la trop grande centralisation de
notre système nous devons aller plus
loin dans la décentralisation faire
confiance au territoire et acteurs de
terrain comme d'autres pays en Europe S
sont employés en attendant des pistes de
réduction de dépenses existent en plus
des mesures de lutte contre la fraude
bien enrichie par le Sénat l'accent doit
surtout être mis sur la prévention et
l'éducation à la santé nous soutenons
toutes les mesures qui vont dans ce sens
sur la vaccination contre le papilloma
virus la campagne nationale dans les
collèges est une excellente j'insiste
initiative de même que sa généralisation
dans ce
PLFSS en effet le papilloma virus à
l'origine de 6400 nouveaux cas par an
c'est un véritable enjeu de santé
publique vaccination et dépistage
peuvent ouvrir la perspective d'une
éradication du cancer du colle de
l'utérus comp tenu de la forte
désinformation sur ce vaccin de la peur
agitée sur des risques supposés bien que
jamais démontrer nous insistons sur
l'importance de renforcer l'information
des jeunes et de leurs familles en amont
des camp campagne de vaccination c'est
l'objet de l'amendement qui a été adopté
à titre personnel mon incompréhension
demeure quant au rejet de toute taxe
supplémentaire sur l'alcool alors que la
méthode a montré son efficacité pour le
tabac et qu'on connaît parfaitement les
risques majeurs que la consommation
d'alcool fait peser sur la santé à
l'origine de 41000 décès par an en
France deuxème cause de mortalité
évitable l'alcool coûte 102 milliards
d'euros à la Société plus de recettes
pour la prévention moins de dépenses sur
la maladie grave évitée ce sont les
enjeux d'une taxe comportementale qui
n'est pas à opposer je le répète à
l'information et à
l'éducation j'espère que nous pourrons
avancer dans le cadre du PLF sur le prix
minimum de l'alcool que nous n'avons pas
pu présenter dans ce PLFSS pour cause
d'irrecevabilité toujours en matière de
prévention nous nous félicitons de voir
enfin un premier pas de fait fait en la
faveur du remboursement de l'activité
physique adaptée pour les patients
atteints de cancer c'est un sujet que je
fend de longue date et je suis
satisfaite de voir l'amendement de mon
groupe adopté avec le soutien du
gouvernement et de la Commission et de
la commission pour les autres mesures
visant à réduire les dépenses je
soutiens un titre personnel certaines
dispositions du texte issu de
l'Assemblée l'application sans délai de
la réforme de la T2A l'interdiction de
prescrire des arrêts maladies de plus de
3 jours en téléconsultation l'incitation
au transport sanitaire partagé ou encore
la délivrance de médicaments à l'unité
en cas de rupture d'approvisionnement ce
sont des mesures de sobriété et de bon
sens dont certaines je le regrette ont
été
supprimées nous nous réjouissons de
l'adoption de certains amendements que
nous défendons des amendements de
justice de cohérence et de
simplification comme le report de la
date d'inscription des départements
volontaires au nouveau régime de
financement des éepades la pérennisation
du Tode donner aux EPCI gérant les aides
à domicile les mêmes avantage que se
donné au CCAS pour toutes ces
raisons lorsque l'on fait la balance
entre entre les bonnes mesures et les
moins bonnes mesures les amendements que
nous avons adaptés ce qui nous semble
manquer dans ce
PLFSS le groupe la majorité du groupe
RDSE s'abstiendra sur ce texte mais
avant de finir j'aimerais insister sur
l'importance d'acter comme le ministre
de la Santé s'y est engagé la
suppression du coefficient de minoration
pour les établissements privés à but non
lucratif il pénalise injustement les
centres de lutte contre le cancer et les
hôpitaux qui sur de nombreux territoires
dont le mien Assur seul l'émission de de
service public auprès de la population
j'aimerais également vous parler de mon
département monsieur madame la ministre
aux frontières de la Belgique et du
Luxembourg où nous subissons la double
peine en plus de la situation nationale
des pénuries de soignant la concurrence
frontalière fragilise grandement nos
hôpitaux et nos soins de premier recours
nos professionnels de santé sont aspirés
le mot n'est pas très beau mais ça
reflète bien la réalité par le
Luxembourg où les salaires sont deux à
trois fois plus élevés j'ai proposé via
un amendement la prise en compte de la
concurrence frontalière dans la
définition des zones bénéficiant du
coefficient géographique il a été rejeté
mais le ministre a semblé ouvert à
d'autres piste nous avons besoin du
gouvernement pour avancer sur ces sujets
je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant au
président Dominique Théophile pour le
groupe du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et
indépendant vous avez la parole monsieur
le
président
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nous arrivons donc au terme de
l'examen de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale de
2024 ce texte s'inscrit dans un contexte
difficile nous l'avons dit pour notre
système de santé fragilisé par une
inflation forte et une augmentation de
ses coûts de fonctionnement l'objectif
de ce texte était clair soutenir les
établissements de santé les plus
fragiles permettre personnel soignant de
gagner dignement sa vie sans que les
avancées du séur ne soient effacé
moderniser et mieux prendre en charge
les patients dans notre pays un objectif
et un horizon la maîtrise des dépenses
et du déficit et la recherche d'économie
quand cela est possible dans les
différentes branches notamment dans les
soins de ville soutien au plus précaire
avec la simplification de l'attribution
de la complémentaire santé solidaire
réforme du financement des hôpitaux
intens ation de la lutte contre la
fraude sociale renforcement des
compétences des pharmaciens et lutte
contre les pénuries de médicaments les
avancées contenues dans ce texte sont
nombreuses deux orientations en
particulier sont à souligner le soutien
à l'autonomie et le renforcement de la
prévention le soutien à l'autonomie
d'abord 39,9 milliards d'euros seront
engagés en 2024 pour renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers adapter
l'offre médico-sociale aux besoins des
phique et améliorer la qualité des
accompagnants soulignons notamment la
mise en place désormais sous la forme
d'une
expérimentation d'une fusion des
sections soins et dépendance dans
certains départements en vue de la
création de nouvelles places de service
de soins infirmiers à domicile le
renforcement attendu de la prévention
ensuite avec 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaires destiné à la
généralisation de la vaccination contre
les les infections à
papillomavirus ou la prise en charge
intégrale des protections périodiques
réutilisables et les préservatifs pour
les moins de 26 ans je tiens par
ailleurs à saluer madame la ministre
l'adoption d'un amendement du
Gouvernement permettant la prise en
charge du sport sur ordonance c'est un
signal très positif qui s'inscrit
pleinement dans la grande cause
nationale souhaitée par le Président de
la République c'est une mesure que vous
savez attendu tout particulièrement dans
les territoires ultramarins au cours de
ces débats notre groupe a formulé un
certain nombre de propositions nous nous
réjouissons de l'adoption de certaines
d'entre elles je pense aux amendements
portés par notre collègue Xavier
yacovelli qui ont permis d'alourdir la
taxation des produits les plus sucré
afin de ralentir la progression de
l'obésité et du diabète et inciter les
industriels à proposer des produits plus
sain je pense également à l'amendement
permettant à un orphelin handicapé de
ficier sans condition d'âge d'une
pension de réversion à la suite du décès
d'un ou de ses deux parents un
amendement de notre collègue Nadj avet
permettra de poursuivre les efforts
engagés en faveur d'une mobilité plus
sobre et décarboné en facilitant le
remboursement des frais de location de
vélo par l'employeur un amendement de
notre collègue Solange nadille donne par
ailleurs la possibilité d'étendre la
liste des vaccinations obligatoire
contre les causes de ménagite aigu afin
de prévenir la recou d'esence de ces
infections mes chers collègues ces
avancées sociales et sanitaires auraient
dû conduire notre groupe à voter en
faveur de ce projet de loi ce texte
budgétaire pourutant nous ne le voterons
pas pour la 2e année consécutive vous
avez en effet souhaité supprimer
l'objectif national de dépenses de
l'assurance maladie lame au motif qu'il
serait flou et insincère
lui reprochant tout à la fois de ne pas
prévoir ce qu'il ne peut pas prévoir et
d'être insuffisamment maîtrisé quand il
s'avère chaque année
insuffisant dans cette même logique vous
avez rejeté la trajectoire des comptes
de la Sécurité sociale pour les
prochaines années trajectoire que vous
avez jugé insuffisamment ambitieuse tout
en choisissant d'ajouter un milliard
d'euros d'exonération supplémentaire
dans un chasser croisé que N nous qui
nous convint pas nous ne sommes pas non
plus convaincus pour le report à 2028 de
la réforme du financement des
établissements de santé et avec elle la
tarification à l'activité la T2A cette
réforme est attendue elle est prête
ayons le courage de la mener un mot
enfin sur la révision sur les révisions
des coefficients géographiques appliqués
aux établissements de santé situés dans
les territoires ultramarins et tout
particulièrement en Guadeloupe
l'engagement du ministre à maintenir ce
taux à 27 % malgré les les études qui
montrent que le taux est inférieur à 25
% a été accueilli avec soulagement sans
pour autant effacer toutes les craintes
les professionnels de santé appellent en
effet à la création de missions
d'intérêt général propre aux outromè
afin de prendre en compte les déficits
structurels auxquels ils font face je
pense notamment à l'accessibilité des
établissements ou à la prévalence de
certaines maladies chroniques au cours
de ces 5 jours de débat c'est au fond la
question l'ininante de la réforme
structurelle de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui s'est imposée le
gouvernement doit l'entendre le Sénat
doit s'en emparer notre groupes ne peut
se satisfaire d'une version désormais
sans réelle cohérence et qui aussi entre
des mesures sociales et sanitaires
ambitieuses et des objectifs en matière
de dépenses publiques désormais flous et
très éloignés de ceux que nous nous
sommes fixés c'est donc en toute logique
que notre groupe s'abstiendra
permettez-moi avant de céder la parole
de remercier les ministres pour les
précisions bienvenues qu'ils ont apporté
au cours de ces débats précisions
attendu et écouté bien au-delà de notre
hmicycle et bien sûr au nos rapporteurs
avec ce travail conséquent pour ce texte
là merci
beaucoup merci mon chers
collègue il va être procédé dans les
conditions prévues par l'article 56 du
règlement au scrutin public solennel sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 le scrutin va être ouvert dans
quelques
instants je vous invite à insérer votre
carte de vote dans le terminal et à
laisser jusqu'au vote si vous disposez
d'une délégation de vote le nom du
sénateur pour lequel vous devez voter
s'affiche automatiquement sur le
terminal en dessous de votre nom vous
pouvez alors voter pour vous et pour
pour le délégant en sélectionnant le nom
correspondant puis en choisissant une
position de vote le scrutin est
ouvert VO là c'est tout ou c'est
parfa
quelqu'un demande encore à
voter le scrutin est donc
clos la
feuille
si les résultats du scrutin numéro 56
sur l'ensemble du texte contte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
nombre de votants
342 nombre de suffrag exprimés
292 pour l'adoption 184 contre 108 le
Sénat a
[Applaudissements]
adopté
je donne la parole maintenant à Monsieur
Thomas kaznav ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics merci Monsieur le
monsieur le Président bon vous avez
adopté le le projet de loi de
financement de la la sécurité
sociale nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
tout mais je mais je crois que ce débat
aura permis de montrer des points de
convergence entre nous je pense au gel
des bandeaux familles à la réforme pour
les indépendants et quelques points de
de divergence sur les travailleurs des
des plateformes ou bien même la
suppression de long d'â qui peut nous
poser quelques difficulté euh je
regrette par ailleurs et vous m'en
voudriez si je ne le faisais pas que
entendant euh les différents orateurs
s'inquiétter du déficit de la Sécurité
sociale que je partage avec vous
constater qu'à l'issue de ces débats le
déficit de la Sécurité sociale se
retrouve aggravé de plus de 1,3
milliards d'euros par des dépenses
supplémentair et et des moindres
recettes enfin je voudrais quand même
terminer sur une tonalité très positive
remercier le président la rapporteur
générale les rapporteurs les sénatrices
et sénateurs avec lesquels je crois on a
pu échanger dialoguer de de façon à la
fois cordiale et et précise et pour cela
je voudrais vous en
remercier merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Madame anè cmain lebudau
ministre délégué en charge de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE
madame merci monsieur le Président tout
d'abord comme mon collègue remercier la
rapporteur et monsieur le Président et
vous mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
pour la qualité de nos débats comme l'a
rappelé monsieur casna nous n'avons pas
été d'accord sur tout nous avons même
parfois eu des désaccords réels mais je
crois que nous nous rejoignions tous sur
un point il nous faut doter notre pays
d'un budget de la Sécurité sociale et et
oui monsieur jaumier il nous faut bien
maintenir notre système solidaire c'est
bien l' système de sécurité sociale
c'est bien notre bien commun à tous
rappelez que ce budget c'est un budget
de responsabilité avec quand même 8
milliards de plus plus de 50 milliards
de plus sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale depuis
2017 pour accompagner la refondation de
notre système de santé pour accompagner
les nécessaires mesures d'attractivité
c'est aussi un budget all dire autour
d'axe important comme ça a été rappelé
tout d'abord la modernisation du
fonctionnement de notre système de santé
la réforme de la T21 ça n'est pas joué
avec l'hôpital comme j'ai cru l'entendre
dire c'est bien prendre en compte une
nécessaire évolution de la tarification
et de l'évolution de notre système de
santé les délégations de tâchees ça
n'est pas que deux nouvelles délégations
de tâchees c'est depuis 2 ans 20
délégations de tâches qui ont été votées
et qui sont mises en œuvre et qui
doivent être mis en œuvre c'est le
travail qui qui est nécessaire de mettre
en action la deuxième ambition c'est
bien d'assurer le virage de la
prévention et rappeler que les
préservatif c'est bel et bien un outil
de prévention c'est aussi de nouveau
levier contre la pénurie des médicaments
c'est aussi le message que le
gouvernement a entendu sur la Loutte
contre la faude et c'est aussi un
travail à mener contre les rendez-vous
lapin et nous vous rejoignons sur ce
sujet je me rejouis aussi sur l'avancée
de l'activité physique adaptée sur une
expérimentation pour accompagner les
personnes victimes de cancer donc ce
PLFSS c'est un PLFSS j'allais dire
réaliste ambitieux et soutenable nous
prenons acte qu'ici il est voté sans
ondâ et l'ondâ c'est bien un outil
nécessaire pour ce budget de la Sécurité
sociale je tiens à le
rappeler
merci merci Madame la rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
tous les rapporteurs qui euh ont préparé
et débattu euh de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale je
vais maintenant suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 16h pour le débat sur le
thème déclinaison territoriale de la
planification écologique quel rôle et
quels moyen pour les collectivités
locales quel accompagnement du citoyen
la séance est
suspendue